la terre est condamné c'est ce que nous
affirment les chercheurs qui étudient la
vie des étoiles quand notre soleil aura
fait son temps il se dilatera jusqu'à
atteindre plusieurs fois son volume
actuel provoquant l'évaporation de notre
atmosphère
peut-être même engloutir at-il toute la
terre avant de se contracter et de
disparaître
première bonne nouvelle nous ne serons
pas là pour assister au spectacle
le soleil n'explosera que dans 5
milliards d'années
deuxième bonne nouvelle la mort du
soleil sera à l'origine de la création
d'une autre génération des toiles car
comme le phénix renaissant de ses
cendres
les étoiles mourantes insuffle à la
galaxie une vie nouvelle
lorsque par une nuit étoilée
nous observons le ciel nous avons le
sentiment que les étoiles sont éternels
mais cette permanence des étoiles est la
plus grande illusion de la nature si
nous pouvions scruter le ciel pendant
des millions d'années nous verrions que
les étoiles naissent vieillissent et
meurent
une analyse approfondie du ciel nocturne
révèle des étoiles de tous les âges
la constellation de la lyre par exemple
comprend vega une étoile blanc bleuté
qui compte parmi les plus jeunes et les
plus actifs de la galaxie et dans la
constellation du scorpion la rouge
antarès est une étoile froide sur le
déclin les étoiles naissent dans des
nébuleuses aux noms évocateurs comme le
lagon trifide ou l'aigle grâce au
télescope spatial hubble
placé en orbite loin au dessus de
l'atmosphère terrestre
les astronomes ont pu être témoins dans
ces amas gazeux de la naissance de
petits soleils
ils ont également pu étudier des
nébuleuses tels que l'hélice l'anneau
et l'esquimau ces cercles de fumée
célestes sont en fait les derniers
soupirs des toiles mourante
les astronomes ont même étudié les
vestiges des toiles morte dans une
formidable explosion il y à des milliers
d'années
c'est incroyable photo du cycle de la
vie des étoiles nous ont donné une autre
approche de la notion même de vie le
carbone et le constituant fondamental de
tous les êtres vivants sur la terre
or sans le cycle de vie des étoiles il
n'y aurait pas un seul atome de carbone
dans toute la galaxie
autrefois les hommes pensé qu'on pouvait
transformer les éléments sans valeur en
élément précieux
les alchimistes cherchait ainsi à
changer le plomb en or et en argent
nous savons maintenant que c'est
impossible du moins sur terre et dans
les étoiles c'est ce qui se produit
et c'est cette alchimie céleste qui a
fabriqué tous les éléments dont nous
sommes faits le carbone à la base de
toute vie là zot qui est dans l'air
l'oxygène que nous respirons le faire
dans notre sens le calcium dans l'eau
zoo tout cela a été créée par les
étoiles l'histoire de la jeunesse de ces
éléments est vraiment passionnante
commençons par une étoile simple comme
notre soleil
le soleil est une sphère d'hydrogène
incandescent en combat constant contre
son champ gravitationnel les forces de
gravitation qui tendent à faire imploser
la sphère du soleil sont en effet
contrecarrée par la pression du
rayonnement de son coeur chaud en fait
le soleil est un réacteur nucléaire très
bien équilibrée il produit de l'énergie
depuis des milliards d'années par la
combustion de son hydrogène en hélium et
il fait ça depuis près de quatre
milliards et demi d'années tout en
restant pratiquement stable ce qui se
transforme dans le soleil c'est sa
composition chimique pas dans les
couches extérieures mais dans son noyau
l'hydrogène se transforme
progressivement en hélium
c'est une fois qu'il n'y aura plus
d'hydrogène du tout que les véritables
changements auront lieu le soleil se
mettra alors à enfler et se transformera
en géante rouge
cette expansion soudaine aura lieu
lorsque la réserve d'hélium accumulés
par le vieux soleil prendra feu la
soudaine libération d'énergie fera alors
de lui une géante rouge
mais cette gigantesque étoile en manque
de combustible n'aura qu'une courte
durée de vie
son noyau fabriquera des éléments de
plus en plus lourd pour tenter de se
maintenir en combustion mais à mesure
que les couches extérieures de son
atmosphère distendu s'éloigneront la
gravitation menacera de faire imploser
ce noyau
finalement le feu centrale s'éteindra
les régions intérieures se refroidit
rond et le reste se dispersera si l'on
en croit nos observations d'autres
étoiles
le soleil se dépouillera progressivement
de ses couches gazeuse pour former un
anneau cosmique brillant appelée
nébuleuse planétaire
une dénomination trompeuse car ces
immenses à bailly matériels n'ont rien à
voir avec des planètes mais au 18e
siècle
l'astronome anglais william herschel cru
voir dans ses disques translucide des
planètes fantomatique
ils les baptise a donc nébuleuses
planétaires et le nom est resté une
nébuleuse planétaire représente le
dernier stade de l'évolution d'une
étoile comme le soleil
nous pensons que d'ici 5 milliards
d'années le soleil aura épuisé son
carburant nucléaire
il connaîtra une expansion angers entre
ont juste multipliant par 50 ou 100 son
diamètre actuelle puisse écoute
extérieurs se perdront dans l'espace
laissant derrière elle le noyau central
ce choeur show enverra des rayons
ultraviolets dans les gaz environnant
les faisant briller et leur donnant
l'apparence d'une nébuleuse comme la
nébuleuse de l'anneau puis cette
nébuleuse se dissipera progressivement
dans l'espace
le choeur restant sur à peu à peu et
deviendra ce qu'on appelle une naine
blanche
et que devient la terre dans tout cela
dit la terre finira-t-elle dans la glace
dans le feu en fait nous aurons d'abord
droit aux feux puis à la glace d'abord
la géante rouge réduira la terre en
cendres et ensuite ce qui en restera
gèlera
lorsque le soleil deviendra une même
blanche et disparaîtra bien sûr nous ne
pouvons pas en être absolument sûr
quelques astronomes prévoit un scénario
encore plus catastrophique selon lequel
le soleil s'agrandirait jusqu à
engloutir complètement la terre celle ci
serait alors aspirer vers l'intérieur du
soleil est désintégré avant d'atteindre
son noyau
le soleil quant à lui finira non pas
dans un grand bang mais dans un murmure
il n'explosera pas en supernova à la
manière des étoiles plus volumineuse les
supernovas projettent leurs débris dans
l'espace fournissant ainsi la matière
première nécessaire à l'élaboration de
nouvelles étoiles et planètes
quand notre soleil se changera en
nébuleuses planétaires lui aussi
dispersera ses composants mais la
transition se fera de manière moins
brutale les nébuleuses planétaires
contribue surtout à fournir de la zot
une bonne part de la zot qu'on trouve
sur la terre provient des toiles qui
n'ont pas explosé mais dont l'atmosphère
s'est dissipée sous forme de nébuleuses
planétaires est pour moi la plus grande
réussite du télescope spatial hubble
sont les magnifiques photos de
nébuleuses planétaires les nébuleuses
que hubble a permis de photographier ont
été baptisés de noms évocateurs comme
spiro graf
le biréacteur la fourmi et la nébuleuse
préféré des astronomes amateurs l'oeil
de chat à trois mille années lumière de
nous elle affiche un tourbillon de gaz
coloré complexe mais remarquablement
symétrique
ce sont des photos comme celle ci prises
par hubble qui ont obligé les astronomes
à revoir leur théorie sur la formation
des nébuleuses planétaires
on dirait un arroseurs automatiques
quand elle tournait projette de la
matière dans différentes directions nous
pensons que l'étoile vibre tandis
qu'elle projette de la matière dans
toutes les directions
mais pourquoi fait-elle ça ça reste un
mystère
peut-être est-ce dû à des champs
magnétiques ou à l'action d'une étoile
ou même d'une planète compagnon plus
généralement nous découvrons que presque
toutes les nébuleuses planétaires ne
sont pas ronde comme nous le pensions
mais allonge et même la fameuse
nébuleuse de l'anneau qui à première vue
semble ronde a probablement fait une
structure cylindrique ou en forme de
tonneau
elle ne sembleraient donc prendre que de
notre point de vue et or est un aspect
beaucoup plus allongée sous un autre
angle
la nébuleuse de l'hélice situé à 450
années lumière et la nébuleuse
planétaire la plus proche de la terre
tout près d'elles se trouve une naine
blanche ratatiner dont les couches
extérieures se sont dispersés il y
environ dix mille ans le télescope
spatial nous a permis de voir à
l'intérieur de l'hélice et nous avons
découvert des centaines de petites
moules gazeuses du moins petit en
apparence sur la fameuse photographie de
l'hélice on voit des traînées de
matières expulsés de ces noeuds très
dense et qui forment ce qui ressemble à
des comètes
bien qu'on ait affaire ici à un ordre de
grandeur bien plus grand que dans notre
propre système solaire
ces boules font en fait plusieurs fois
la taille de notre système solaire tout
entier d'eau gigantesque début leuze une
population extrêmement diversifiée des
toiles d'innombrables planète toutes ces
merveilles font partie d'une cité des
toiles nommé la galaxie de la voie
lactée
tout comme une ville cette cité change
d'aspect au fil du temps et bien qu'elle
semble assez statique il s'y passe
énormément de choses
à
notre galaxie est immense une fusée se
déplaçant à la vitesse de la lumière
la vitesse limite de la galaxie mettrait
environ cent mille ans pour la traversée
ici vivent quelques centaines de
milliards des toiles notre soleil et son
cortège de planètes réside dans une
banlieue plutôt éloigné du centre ville
une zone assez étendue et tranquille
comme le sont la plupart des régions
périphériques de la galaxie dans cette
zone
les étoiles sont de masse de luminosité
et de couleurs très variées des crèches
et des cimetières stellaire parsèment le
paysage du moins le supposons nous et la
tâche des astronomes consiste à ordonner
toutes ces informations en un tout
cohérent
dans ce but des radios astronomes du
monde entier se sont regroupés dans le
cadre du relevé du plan galactique
ils mettent en commun leurs données pour
cartographier la voie lactée de façon la
plus précise possible
cette entreprise a commencé au milieu
des années 90 à l'observatoire national
de recherche radioastronomie qu situé
près de painting tonnes en
colombie-britannique se télescopent à
synthèse d'ouverture est muni de
plusieurs paraboles reliée
électroniquement qui fonctionne comme
une seule gigantesque antenne il scrute
la voie lactée à la recherche d' onde
radio émises par les atomes d'hydrogène
l'élément le plus abondant de la galaxie
la constellation du cygne est une riche
tapisseries des toiles et de nuages
d'hydrogène qui apparaissent en rouge
sur cette image optique mais grâce aux
techniques d'observation radio et aux
satellites on peut désormais déceler des
objets difficiles ou impossibles à
détecter de façon optique dans cette
région de la voie lactée des étoiles
géantes naissent et meurent et les
résidus de plusieurs explosions
stellaires sont visibles des nébuleuses
compact indique la présence d'une étoile
récemment formé enveloppée d'un voile
danse de gaz chauds des vents stellaires
provenant d'autres jeunes étoiles et
probablement aussi d'explosion anciennes
ont modelé des nuages de gaz et de
poussières en longs filaments courbe
ces gaz et ces poussières constituent ce
que les astronomes appellent le milieu
interstellaire ce milieu contient
surtout de l'hydrogène et il est
extrêmement ténus sa température est de
plus de 240 degrés en dessous de zéro
par endroits le milieu interstellaire se
concentrent en nuage moléculaire danse à
mâcon centre et de gaz et de poussière
c'est là que se forment les étoiles
les astronomes attendent beaucoup de
l'étude de ces nuages moléculaires
mais pour y voir clair il doit faire
appel aux radiotélescopes nous utilisons
des radiotélescopes parce que dans ces
régions très dense composé
majoritairement de gaz
il est environ 1% de grains de poussière
extrêmement fins qui intercepte la
lumière l'absorbent et la disperse
donc si on observe une de ces régions à
l'aide d'un télescope optique on voit un
amas d'étoilés tout autour mais la zone
qui nous intéresse est tout noir
on ne peut rien voir on dirait une zone
absolument vide mais dès qu'on fait
appel aux ondes radio celle inverse
les ondes radio pénètre à l'intérieur de
ces zones de fines poussières ce qui
permet aux radiotélescopes d'enregistrer
ce qu'elles contiennent ces nuages glacé
étant de puissants émetteurs d'ondés
radio leur structure peut être analysé
en détail et les systèmes stellaires en
formation dans ces nuages produisent ce
aussi des ondes radio en somme la
différence entre une étoile et le milieu
interstellaire c'est que l'étoile est
très dense pour former une étoile
il faut donc prendre une portion de ce
milieu est équivalente à la masse de
notre soleil donc étendu sur un diamètre
de 3 à 5 années lumière et la compresser
en quelque chose d'assez petit et chaud
pour devenir une étoile
les régions qui se densifie sont aussi
celles qui sont les plus froides elles
finissent par se réchauffer quand il y
as formation d'une étoile
mais au début lors de la phase où les
matières convergent vers le centre
elles sont extrêmement froides elles ont
une action refroidi sentent elles
renvoient l'énergie dégagée par la
formation de nombreuses molécules la
théorie de la formation des étoiles est
simple un amas d'hydrogène se contracte
sous l'effet de la gravitation jusqu'à
devenir si petit et si chaud qu'il
déclenche des réactions de fusion
nucléaire qui font briller la nouvelle
étoile
mais il ne faut pas que l'ama se
réchauffe trop vite sinon ils cessent de
se contracter
afin de se condenser en étoile il doit
donc se débarrasser de son excès de
chaleur
on suppose que c'est là qu'interviennent
certaines molécules et principalement
l'eau mais cette théorie est maintenant
remise en question par les observations
du radiotélescope placé en orbite autour
de la terre est appelée soir ou
satellite astronomique à ondes sub
millimétrique le soit 7 est conçu
principalement pour y déceler dans les
zones de formation d'étoilés des
molécules spécifiques qui sont
essentielles pour comprendre le
processus de création d'une étoile
l'une de ses molécules et l'eau et
l'autre l'oxygène moléculaire les
molécules d'eau émettent des ondes radio
que les antennes des satellites sont en
mesure de capter et ses ondes en autant
de l'énergie à la nébuleuse servent à la
refroidir
s'il contient assez d'eau un nuage
interstellaire pourra ainsi rester froid
assez longtemps pour se condenser en un
amas d'étoilés
l'équipe du soir est donc parti à la
recherche d'eau dans l'espace elle en a
rapporté de bonnes et de mauvaises
nouvelles
nous avons découvert qu'il y avait de
l'eau absolument partout dans la galaxie
et nous avons examiné de nombreuses
régions mais elle est bien moins
abondante que ce que nous pensions
environ 100 à 1000 fois moins que ce que
nos modèles nous laisser supposer
le soir a également recherché de
l'oxygène les molécules d'oxygène
pourrait comme celle de l'eau aider à
refroidir la nébuleuse lors de sa
période de formation et de plus
l'oxygène est un élément vital est
constitutif de bien des choses qui nous
sont chères les rochers le sol l'air et
enfin nous mêmes
d'où l'intérêt de rechercher de
l'oxygène dans les régions où se forment
les planètes et les étoiles dans le
reste de la galaxie l'oxygène semble
bien plus rare que dans le système
solaire environ trois fois plus rares on
peut donc se demander est ce que la
terre est ce que notre système solaire
sont des endroits exceptionnels
avons-nous plus d'oxygène que le reste
de la galaxie où l'oxygène se dissimule
t-il sous une forme que nous n'avons pas
encore su détecter l'oxygène que
recherchait le soir et de l'oxygène
atomique
en termes de structure chimique il
s'agit tout simplement d'atomes
d'oxygène isolé mais peut-être les
atomes d'oxygène dans l'espace sajan
style par paire comme ils ont tendance à
le faire
l'oxygène cosmique pourrait ainsi se
cacher sous forme d'oxygène moléculaire
semblable à celui que nous respirons
nous avons examiné plusieurs régions
mais n'avons jamais trouvé d'oxygène
moléculaire nulle part après des
centaines d'heure d'observation de zone
précise du ciel se télescopent nous
permet d'avoir un signal d'une pureté
sans précédent et nous n'avons trouvé
d'oxygène moléculaire nulle part
la question demeure donc la terre fait
elle figure d'exception et yat-il très
peu d'oxygène dans le reste de la
galaxie l'oxygène se cache-t-il dans un
endroit inconnu ou sous une forme que
nous ne savons pas décelé le mystère
reste donc entier et nous travaillons à
le résoudre
depuis cette interview
l'équipe du soir a découvert quelques
systèmes stellaires où l'eau semble
exister en abondance mais on ignore
toujours pourquoi les ressources d'eau
varie selon les systèmes et pourquoi il
y à des variations tout court
oxygène hydrogène carbone faire aux
hôtes le milieu interstellaire contient
tous ces éléments et d'autres encore en
diverses quantités
tous viennent de l'intérieur des toiles
et serviront à en créer de nouvelles
comment fonctionne cette machine à
recycler galactique
la réponse est dans le feu d'artifice le
plus spectaculaire de la nature
l'explosion d'une supernova
notre soleil se contentera peut-être de
disparaître en silence mais les étoiles
les plus massives elles s'éteignent avec
fracas les plus grandes étoiles de la
voie lactée meurt dans un éclair
aveuglant appelées supernovas ces
étoiles consomme tous leurs hydrogène en
à peine quelques millions d'années puis
la gravité prend le dessus et elle se
met à se contracter
ceci met le feu à d'autres réserves de
carburant comme l'hélium et le carbone
et l'étoile devient une géante rouge
mais quand ces réserves sont elles aussi
épuisé la source interne de chaleur
s'arrête et il n'y a plus assez de
pression pour garantir l'intégrité de
l'étoile son coeur se contractent et ses
couches extérieures s'effondre en
quelques secondes le noyau devient si
dense que les matières qui tombe dessus
rebondissent en une onde de choc qui se
propage à travers toutes les toiles
lorsque l'on atteint la surface de
l'étoile celle ci explose en un feu
d'artifice cosmique la lumière de la
supernova devient alors plus forte que
les lumières de toutes les étoiles de sa
galaxie réunis nous avons pu observer ce
phénomène sur des supernovas situés dans
des galaxies éloignées de plusieurs
millions d'années lumière lors de
l'explosion d'une supernova la
gravitation réduit le noyau de l'étoile
à une boule incroyablement dense appelée
étoile à neutrons les neutrons sont des
particules subatomiques qui avec les
protons forment le noyau d'un atome
une étoile à neutrons atteint un volume
tellement compacte que toutes les
particules subatomiques qui s'y trouvent
se transforme en neutron la gravité a
réduit les toiles à sa plus petite
taille possible en la convertissant en
énorme noyaux atomiques
c'est très très dense imaginez une masse
qui ferait une fois et demi le soleil
réduite à la taille d'une petite ville
d'un rayon disons d'environ 10 km c'est
très dense une cuillère à café de
matière d' étoile à neutrons passe donc
plusieurs tonnes et comme si ce n'était
pas suffisant
ces étoiles sont en rotation très rapide
une étoile à neutrons classique fait
plusieurs tours par seconde
mais les plus rapides à notre
connaissance font plus de 600 tours par
seconde il faut s'imaginer quelque chose
d'aussi dans ce tournant à la vitesse
d'une centrifugeuse certaines étoiles à
neutrons semble présenter des tâches
brillante sur leur surface
leurs rotations fait apparaître ses
points plusieurs fois par seconde
donnant l'impression de clignotement ou
de pulsations qui font qu'on appelle ses
étoiles à neutrons des pulsars le plus
jeune et le plus étudié des pulsars que
nous ayons découvert est enveloppée dans
un nuage de débris tourbillonnant appelé
la nébuleuse du kram
le crabe est l'un des plus célèbres
vestiges de supernova ce pulsar nous
envoie des signaux lumineux d'une
régularité à plat câble 30 fois par
seconde la plus brillante des supernovas
du ciel semble ainsi nous faire signe
pour attirer notre attention
mission réussie sinon considère que
l'intérêt qu'elle suscite remonte à des
temps très reculés il y as presque mille
ans les astronomes de la cour impériale
chinoise ont observé ce qu'ils ont nommé
une étoile hôte dans la constellation du
taureau
c'était en l'an mil 54 de notre
calendrier et la supernova été si
brillante qu'elle a été visible en plein
jour pendant trois semaines et il a
fallu près d'un an avant qu'elle ne
disparaisse du ciel nocturne
des siècles plus tard des astronomes ont
mesuré ce pulsar grâce à leurs
télescopes
on a ainsi découvert que le crabe
s'accroissait au rythme de plus de 1500
kilomètres par seconde et qu'il faisait
plusieurs milliers de fois la taille de
notre système solaire
bien que la nébuleuse du crabe soit très
éloignées selon des critères terrestre
elle est à environ 6500 années lumière
elle se transforme si rapidement que
nous pouvons la voir changer au fil du
temps surtout grâce au télescope hubble
quand on la regarde à plusieurs tentes
et successifs
on constate qu'elle a changé d'aspect la
nébuleuse du crabe a été observés
régulièrement avec hubble qui permet de
faire des gros plans de la région
centrale est de voir le pulsar mais
aussi tous les phénomènes qui
l'entourent une série de ces clichés a
même été transformé en film
tout change si vite dans cette nébuleuse
qu'on peut voir les choses évoluent en
l'espace de quelques semaines ou mois on
voit des cercles concentriques un peu
comme si on jetait une pierre dans un
étang des ondes concentriques qui
s'éloigne du centre
on peut également voir que le pulsar qui
tourne à 30 tours par seconde en vo
qu'un vent qui va du centre vers
l'extérieur et influe sur la matière
interstellaire qui entoure le pulsar
lorsqu'on s'éloigne un peu de cette
nébuleuse
on observe les interactions du
rayonnement synchrotron qui entoure le
pulsar avec les débris l'explosion ces
filaments comme nous les appelons ce qui
apparaît sans couleurs vives sur les
photos prises par hubble sont
littéralement de la matière des toiles
ce sont les couches extérieures et
intérieures de l'étoile qui ont été
rejetés dans l'espace et qui
participeront probablement à la
formation de nouvelles étoiles mais
toutes les grandes étoiles ne finisse
pas en étoile à neutrons les plus
gigantesques connaissent un sort plus
étrange encore lorsqu'une étoile immense
devient une supernova les couches
extérieures sont expulsés mais le noyau
lui implose complètement
les forces nucléaires qui assurent la
cohésion des étoiles à neutrons ne
suffisent plus à contrer le champ
gravitationnel soudain amplifié à
l'extrême et le noyau est aspiré dans un
tourbillon cosmique
il se réduit à un point et disparaît
faisons un trou dans l'espace temps et
ne laissant derrière lui que son champ
gravitationnel l'ancienne étoile géante
est devenue un trou noir
par nature les trous noirs sont
difficiles à détecter
mais il existe une façon indirecte de
les découvrir
si le trou noir fait partie d'un système
des toiles double il va aspirer le gaz
de l'étoile voisine cette matière forme
alors un tourbillon autour du trou noir
avant d'y disparaître
plus les particules s'approche plus elle
tourne rapidement et elle s'échauffe
jusqu'à émettre des rayons x
rayons x qui peuvent être détectées par
des observatoires en orbite la matière
chaude que l'on voit près du trou noir
et mais ces dernières radiations elle
est tout près du bord du trou noir et
bientôt elle sera perdue à jamais pour
l'univers qu'en cette matière tombe dans
le trou noir
elle ne peut plus émettre de radiation
qu'on puisse détecter la gravitation
dans le trou noir est telle que même la
lumière d'un gaz très chaud ou d'atomes
ou de molécules très chaud qui sont au
fond du trou noir ne pourra jamais s'en
échapper il n'y a aucune façon on ou de
détecter quelque chose qui est tombé
dans un trou noir
en d'autres termes toute information
concernant cette matière est perdu et
bien qu'elle se trouve certainement
encore dans l'univers nous n'avons aucun
moyen de la retrouver elle est donc
perdue à jamais
de même que la disparition des plus
grandes étoiles la naissance d'un trou
noir est un phénomène qui s'accompagne
d'une certaine production de déchets de
grandes quantités de matières sont
rejetées dans l'espace où elles
contribueront à la naissance d'une
nouvelle génération de soleil notre
région de la voie lactée est ainsi plein
de matière stellaire au cycle et le
soleil en est un bon exemple
ainsi que les planètes ou nous-mêmes
mais le processus de formation d'une
étoile n'est pas simple et les résultats
ne sont pas garantis
l'espace est plaint d' indices sur la
façon dont naissent les étoiles dont une
bonne part sont facilement repérables
dans certaines parties de la galaxy le
milieu interstellaire brille dans le
noir s'il est excité d'une certaine
façon un nuage d'hydrogène se met à
briller et prend une teinte rouge
caractéristique un bon exemple en est la
nébuleuse du lagon dans la constellation
du sagittaire
cette nébuleuse est soumise à
l'excitation de rayonnements
ultraviolets émis par une douzaine de
jeunes étoiles qui se trouve en son sein
cet amas de jeunes étoiles qui nous
permet d'obtenir de si belles photos du
lagon est aussi la preuve que cette
nébuleuse est en fait une véritable
pépinière des toiles les astronomes
savent que des soleils sont encore en
formation au plus profond de la
nébuleuse
ils savent aussi que souvent leur
naissance on ne va pas sans complication
les milieux étrange qui abrite les
jeunes étoiles peuvent être observés
dans la constellation d'orion l'aspect
caractéristiques dorion est bien connue
des astronomes amateurs sa ceinture de
trois étoiles brillantes est facilement
repérable à l'oeil nu des étoiles moins
brillante indique également la fameuse
nébuleuse d'orion objets favoris des
astronomes amateurs puisqu'elle renferme
l'une des zones de formation d'étoilés
les plus remarquables de nos cieux le
télescope hubble a permis de visualiser
l'intérieur de la nébuleuse d'orion
en plus des jeunes étoiles qui font
briller la nébuleuse il a mis en
évidence des proto étoiles embryonnaires
enveloppé de cocon de poussière les
chercheurs se demandent si des étoiles
et des planètes
naîtront de cet amas de poussière et de
gaz
l'astronome canadien doug johnston a
analysé les photos de hubble pour y
découvrir des traces de naissance des
toiles ce qu'on observe dans la
nébuleuse d'orion est intrigant il
s'agit non seulement d'une des zones de
formation les plus proches de nous mais
aussi de la zone où se forment les
étoiles les plus diverses pour ce qui
est de la masse c'est un fait unique
dans le sens où les étoiles à forte
masse produisent tellement d'énergie
qu'elle influe sur l'environnement des
étoiles plus jeunes si vous observez une
des belles photos de la région du
trapèze dorion vous voyez 4 étoiles
formons un trapèze au milieu d'une
nébuleuse de gaz brillant cette
nébuleuse est en fait du gaz réchauffé
par ses quatre étoiles
ces étoiles dégage énormément d'énergie
et réchauffe toute la matière qui les
entoure a priori les étoiles n'ont pas
de queue mais si vous regardez tout
autour du trapèze
vous voyez de petits objets qui
ressemble à des comètes ce qui se passe
en fait c'est que les jeunes étoiles
sont entourés de disque de matière qui
sont chauffés par les étoiles massives
en se dégageant du disque la matière se
met à briller comme une comète et le
vent émis par les étoiles massives
repousse cette matière et lui donne
l'aspect d'une queue de comète
ceci se passe à l'échelle de notre
système solaire ce qui renforce l'idée
que ce disque que nous observons autour
des étoiles font la même taille que
notre système solaire et constitue le
lien entre le processus de formation des
étoiles et celui des planètes
mais johnston et ses collègues ne sont
pas sûrs que des planètes naîtront de
ses disques poussiéreux les grandes
étoiles mène la vie dure à la nouvelle
génération des toiles en pleine
croissance
et si celle-ci ne parviennent pas à
grandir il ne pourra pas y avoir deux
planètes à l'intérieur des disques il
n'est pas certain qu'on aille jusqu'à la
formation des planètes
la nébuleuse d'orion est une région
violente et dangereuse et les disques
sont détruits au bout de l'aps de temps
très court moins d'un million d'années
ça fait long pour vous et moi
mais dans la vie d'une étoile c'est très
bref la naissance des étoiles n'est pas
seulement compromise sur orion
de l'autre côté du firmament dans la
constellation du serpent se trouve une
grande région de formation stellaire
nommé la nébuleuse de l'aigle
à l'intérieur de l'aigle se trouvent des
piliers gigantesque de matières
moléculaire denses et froides qui
surplombe une cavité rempli de gaz
brûlants les radiations intense et manon
des jeunes étoiles de l'aigle frappe ses
piliers et les airs horde à la façon
d'un puissant vent du désert
quand l'astronome jeff hester a analysé
les photos prises par hubble il a
remarqué autre chose à l'intérieur de
tout ça il y avait des étoiles et nous
avons compris que nous observions des
étoiles en cours de formation des noyaux
de gaz rendu visible par l'évaporation
de la matière environnante
hester pense que tandis que leur
enveloppe protectrice se dissipe les
proto et toiles sont exposées à un vent
violent de rayons ultraviolets en
provenance des grands soleils de
génération précédente
les vents de radiation menace de faire
disparaître les gaz essentiels dont ces
embryons des toiles ont besoin pour
grandir les privant peut être même de la
possibilité de devenir des étoiles
apparemment dans le nid de l'aigle tous
les nouveau nés ne survivent pas
l'étoile poursuit sa formation elle
accumule de la matière augmente de
taille et à un moment donné qui est
arbitraire le couperet tombe tu n'auras
plus rien et l'étoile reste à cette
taille parce qu'elle n'a plus de matière
à assimiler voilà ce que nous observons
il s'agit d'un des processus qui
détermine la taille des étoiles la
nébuleuse d'orion et celle de l'aide
sont un peu comme un fusil qui fument
encore et ce fusil qui fument encore
c'est l'effet qu'ont les étoiles
massives chaude sur leur environnement
et sur la formation des toiles
même s'il n'est pas sans faille le
processus de formation des étoiles se
répète partout dans la voie lactée à une
échelle impressionnante est tout aussi
impressionnant et le fait que cette
galaxie contiennent au moins une espèce
d'être pensant qu'ils essaient à tout
prix de découvrir les secrets de
l'univers des êtres qui ont fini par
comprendre que le lien qui les unit aux
étoiles est bien plus fort qu'ils ne
l'avaient imaginé toutes nos enquêtes et
analyses approfondies de la voie lactée
nous on a pris au moins une chose tout
est en relation
notre galaxie est une immense machine à
recycler lors de son explosion finale
la supernova produit tous les éléments
chimiques que nous connaissons les
vestiges de supernova comme la nébuleuse
du crabe regorge de matériaux de
construction galactiques le crabe rouge
est son mélange d'hydrogène et d'autres
éléments plus lourds dans le milieu
interstellaire
au bout d'un certain temps cette matière
ça semblera à d'autres nuages de matière
stellaire pour former de nouvelles
nébuleuse notre soleil ces planètes et
bien sûr notre terre ont été créés au
sein d'une nébuleuse dont les composants
provenaient des toiles morte
il n'est donc pas étonnant que les
astrophysiciens qui étudient les
mystérieux disques de gaz dans la
nébuleuse d'orion soit aussi fasciné par
le ciel nocturne content que chercheur
j'ai le désir de comprendre
voilà pourquoi ce qui m'intéresse
principalement sait comment la matière
se dégage tel de ses disques c'est un
problème de physique mais quand je suis
dans ma résidence secondaire en ontario
et que je m'allonge dans une barque pour
regarder les étoiles comme je le faisais
déjà tout petit je ne m'occupe plus de
physique je regarde la beauté du
spectacle
pour d'autres astronomes cette beauté et
davantage conceptuel que visuel le
simple fait que nous puissions
comprendre un phénomène comme celui de
la formation des étoiles est en soi une
source d'émerveillement
comment les étoiles se forment tel à
l'autre bout de la galaxie à partir
d'une information qui nous parvient de
l'immensité de l'espace juste en
regardant une étoile on peut dire de
quoi est faite cette étoile alors
qu'elle se trouve à l'opposé de la
galaxie c'est absolument fascinant si
les théories des chercheurs sur la façon
dont les étoiles produisent et
redistribue les éléments chimiques sont
exacts ils ont découvert une relation
remarquable entre les étoiles et nous
en résumé les hommes sont faits de
matières des toiles recyclés et nous
devons notre existence aux innombrables
étoiles qui ont existé avant nous
parmi tout ce que nous avons appris en
matière d'astronomie au cours des
dernières décennies
le plus fascinant concerne notre
relation à l'univers et sur le fait que
nous en sommes le produit
au départ nous regardons le ciel et nous
voyons des choses spectaculaires les
coizard éloigner la nébuleuse de l'aigle
des galaxies nous apprenons énormément
de choses et en fin de compte c'est vers
nous mêmes que nous regardons et nous
percevons d'une manière différente qui
nous sommes d'où nous venons et quelle
est notre relation avec tout ce qui nous
entoure nous en savons assez à présent
pour dire qu'au début de l'univers il y
avait de l'hydrogène de l'hélium des
traces de lithium et c'est à peu près
tout mais vous et moi nous ne sommes pas
faits d'hydrogène et d'hélium et de
lithium mais de carbone azote d'oxygène
et de phosphore et nous sommes sur une
planète qui a un noyau en fer nickel
entouré de silicate d'où viennent donc
les autres éléments
la réponse est qu'ils ont été produits à
l'intérieur des toiles les étoiles
obtiennent leur énergie en prenant des
éléments légers qu'elle transforme en
éléments plus lourds au cours d'un
processus continu
mais quel rapport peut-il bien y avoir
avec nous nous ne sommes pas l'intérieur
d'une étoile et bien vers la fin de leur
vie les étoiles rejette cette matière
projette par des vents violents dans des
nébuleuses planétaires et deviennent des
supernova et toute cette pollution
chimique comme on devrait l'appeler
l'héritage chimique de ces étoiles est
rendu à l'espace interstellaire
quand notre soleil
quand notre terre se sont formés il y
avait tout autour des éléments plus
lourds qui ont permis des combinaisons
chimiques intéressantes comme celle qui
ont donné la vie par exemple
que vous regardiez dans cette pièce ou
par la fenêtre les atomes qui forment
toutes les choses que vous voyez on
autrefois fait partie d'une étoile et
ont été créés à l'intérieur d'une étoile
vous et moi faisons partie ce processus
nous sommes le produit final de
l'évolution chimique de la galaxie il ne
s'agit non pas de quelque chose
d'éloigner le lointain de distant mais
de quelque chose qui est
inextricablement liée à notre existence
c'est peut-être ce que l'astronomie a de
plus fascinant aujourd'hui
et